une chose est sûre son fils ska un
nouveau petit jeu devra est ce que c'est
le nouveau fan n'a pas traîné sa
question qu'on se pose dès qu'on découpe
un nouveau petit jeu d'horreur un jeune
femme qui prive de l'histoire vite fait
on est une nounou et on doit s'occuper
d'un vieil homme qui vient d'acheter une
maison à très bon prix pourquoi parce qu
elle est hantée du cul et ça il le sait
pas encore ce qu est à sonder km nous
avons pris ce qu elle est hantée vous un
peu faux pas l'acheter bref elle est
tellement vieille qui a pas
d'électricité les câbles sont revus il
faut les changer donc en gros au doit
s'occuper de charger des générateurs
comme ça vous voyez déjà je pense que le
premier temps on va essayer sur prêts
dans la maison il ya un étage oh là là
[ __ ] bon gars mais c'est abusé
coillard générateur partout mais c'est
quoi le sait bref si je connais pas par
coeur à plus tard le célé où je savais
qu'on allait être baiser là où peut-être
le sait ça ça serait le sait ça ok ça
c'est le sait c'est bon donc ça c'est le
sait d'accord donc on a le a le b le
sait qu'on va écouter pour le moment
tout se passe comme sur des roulettes à
temps c'est pas malin comme comme
mécanique le bc lequel déjà plus tard le
b2b levé le bel mais ça c'est là ça
le bébé ou un bon gars mais c'est trop
dur de se repérer à sa salle b salvet
c'est beau checkpoint au d'accord on a
passé le premier truc on est bien là on
recommence à zéro la ses visions ne
cessa voilà leur néant cette zone aux
caisses quand on est bien loin de tous
les générateurs on va tant que l'un des
générateurs baisse un peu en patates
pour aller le voir bien évidemment et je
crois que quand on entend le bruit de la
meuf ces médias qu'elle est derrière
nous il faut vite se barrer il paraît
logique donc ça c'est le à ça c'est le
bel à eau dans la salle de bain c'est le
sait est en phase celle des on s'en
souviendra
vous allez louis blanc tendu vite fait
on l'entend mais je chie dessus je vais
mal hein je fais plutôt mal invité à sa
décharge le b le bo run run for your
life
c'était quoi ça c'est moi qui ai fait ça
je charge lui j'ai trouvé à l'aube
autour des mecs je vais trouver là
dessus au fond je me 4 ha ok mais ça a
eu sa bombarde un olalala en fait faut
passer une seule nuit mais je crois que
chaque heure c'est pire que leur
président dans le high à une erreur
voyez des fois elle elle corrompt pas un
truc mais faut pas y aller il faut pas y
aller logiquement ça va se remettre tout
seul le b ouais on est pas mal le le à
poilley loubat attente est alors faut
pas y aller [ __ ] merde
aol va être là elle va t-elle à muter la
[ __ ] dans ces bornes et bien on est bien
on retourne au délà eaux d'alet on est
chaud là ok vous voyez il faut qu'on
tienne encore 29 minutes dans le jeu
vous faut surtout et j'arrive pas à
dresser un sniper cette nouvelle a fait
l'armée c'est pas possible je suis
choqué c'est ultra dur [ __ ] ça abusé
voyais arriver
ne paniquons pas est ce que la technique
c'est pas d'attentes que ça ce vide chez
pas aux autos trois quarts pour aller
recharger générateur plutôt que de
courir partout comme un [ __ ] de lapin
dans la maison là avec elle qui nous
fait de vieux croche-patte comme ça le
dejan erreur je me casse ça veut dire
quelle est la ou je me bats mon pays
couilles
on va se mettre là
le plaisir je sais pourquoi nous a sauté
tuco ya le bruit le thing c'est qu'elle
est devant nous et il faut se barrer
courir ok ça fait dix minutes qu' il n'y
a pas de générateurs en baisse ok c'est
parti ok on est bien on est bien on est
bien ok je me casse la barre oui il ya
des bruits de violon toulouges et j'ai
peur ok maintenant falloir aller à
l'étagé le pld qui baissent au hib est
vite an plus tôt mais bien au sepa sepa
se passe passe passe par alstom sont à
la barre ou d'échouer aux photographes
fois laura
en fait si je bouge tout le temps elle
n'arrive pas à me localiser albanie qui
a panique encore plus que non ça c'est
fait [ __ ] on est bien tous les
générateurs sur info on retourne dans la
safe zone
olala rs 12 minutes allaient se décharge
pas ils ne cherchent pas au passé douze
minutes
j'espère jusqu'à neuf c'est bien la fin
on le sait pour qui nous lâchent maïs te
plaît non-stop les normes 9h09 bmc bon
les patterns checkpoints à dwight à 10h
et j'ai envie de chialer [ __ ] faut
être hyper l'otan c'est chaud allez on
remet le sait on est bon je regarde
ailleurs
non cette zone
cette zone j'suis mort chez moi il n'y a
plus rien il ya plus rien mec je pouvais
pas les charges et au savoir-faire bct
quoi ça va je me suis fait chier dessus
mais comme la pire des merdes quoi 9h23
à l'époque était encore 35 minutes mon
gars nous n'avons pas peur de la fille
en sweat adidas un peu trop long pour
elle autrement appelé le pyjama pour
filles et en 2016
en fait je sais pourquoi tout s'éteint
c'est quand vous voyez un des
générateurs des fois qu'ils passent en
mode erreur au bout d'un certain temps
c'est tout le système qui redémarre et
quant au système redémarre battait dans
le noir comme un gros qu'au haut et tout
mon choix c'est pas du tout mon [ __ ]
t'as vu que ce thème va redémarrer je me
mets dans la zone tranquille et
j'attends comment les générateurs ipes
vite maintenant mec
j'arrête de jouer à douze joueurs
j'arrête de jouer j'ai hâte de jouer aux
cartes et aux excès en la violence
hockey dernier essai je suis sûr j'avais
trouvé un jour sur une chaise comme ça
en plus de vidéos ok c'est reparti 10
heures du soir
si tu changes le soir par matin ça
ferait tout de suite 100 fois vendeur et
loue le vieux [ __ ] pourquoi il m'aide
pas avec sa fusée je suis pas là pour
équiper des générateurs [ __ ] moi je
suis là pour donner des biberons
que ce soit des bébés ou allez papy oh
[ __ ] mais depuis le vieux est la
vérité sur ce jeu c'est lui le vieux
voilà c'est un traquenard hockey
dernière et c'est [ __ ] c'est comme le
soir quand tu regardes une série
dernière épisode et je vais me coucher
alors sans lunettes de détective conan
là avec l'antenne de beauté y avait un
éléphant dans la maison quoi l e allô
allô allô allô allô alors on est bon les
brawn est bon on n'est pas trop mal
actuellement le a failli s'éteindre mais
c'est bon on a fait genre ok ça c'est
fait on est pas mal là ça c'est pas là
que je voulais aller à chaque fois je
perds du temps puisque je clique mal
[ __ ] mais c'est bon le allô allô allô
allô on est pas mal on est pas mal nous
reste plus qu'une heure et demie à tenir
vos gars il ya un an
non non non non c'est faux c'est faut
chasser gbagbo a lancé les zones on est
bien on est bien on est bien on est bien
là en fait c'est elle qui a redémarré
tous les générateurs vont garder la
vitesse à laquelle ils s'amusent et
franchement je trouve que là on est pas
mal hein honnêtement on va remonter
aussi directe est là encore entassés des
voisins tu peux tuer tout le quartier
moi ça me dérange pas tant que tu me
laisses moi mon papier mais générateur à
manger tranquille à baisser avec ce jeu
tu veux le résumé en trois mots quoi
voilà papy générateur nounou non non
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
on s'est cachés au cra rien on est à
l'abri
maintenant ça n'était que le danger sa
regarder observer d'activia pas de
danger aller ça fait une heure contient
il reste plus que 55 minutes à tenir
ce jour-là squeeze lui traumatisé il
avait d'abord résisté aux trois tisme
des toilettes japonaises mais sophie du
jeu sophie ce cursus raison de lui
laisser actuellement d'avoir votre
métier pour vous mettiez un petit j'aime
sur sa vidéo et qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent des abonnés web allégeance la
france ou un sursaut facebook n'hésitez
pas à aller mais c'est vous a plu mon
coeur a failli lâcher pour de vrai là le
dernier screamer il ma fille m'a fait du
mal et it et villa ont postés regardez
les lunettes étaient défectueuses elle
n'avait pas repéré le danger va te
casser un bon petit jeu à la fin à une
attente très distant manitou j'aime bien
les jeux d'horreur maintenant ou juste
utiliser le cliq aux la souris puisque
il faut vraiment être attentif à tout
alors je serai une prochaine vidéo merci
d'abord regardé portez vous bien chat au
monde pissas